andreas ist ein netter kerl ich war
unser freund
aber er ist er ist mehr als doppelt so
also durch wände muss doch ein so dass
es nicht funktionieren
nein das ist das perfekte alter okay
wenn ich jetzt eine junge frau okay ich
wäre jetzt 23 angenommen ich wende 23
jahre als junge frau
natürlich suche ich mir dann nur männer
aus die auch mein vater sein könnten
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen video
produktion der youtube anlaufstelle für
menschenrechte sind sämtlich abstoßen
der inhalte bei uns sind in den letzten
tagen diverse meldungen wegen verstören
der inhalte auch einem gewissen
youtube-kanal namens hilf mir
eingegangen genau gesagt hat dass ich
bei diesen beschwerden um das video soll
ich kann nicht mehr es bleiben okay um
das video albtraum mein freund ist
vielleicht mein erzeuger gehandelt ganz
kurz vor dem begriff erzeuger nichts
anfangen können das heißt mein freund
ist vielleicht mein vater ganz ehrlich
war schon ein paar hilfe videos gesehen
hat dann erreicht man den zeitpunkt man
denkt so okay ich habe alles gesehen ich
bin jetzt erfahren mich kann nichts mehr
schocken und dann kommt so ein brett um
die ecke und die frage dabei ist immer
wer wirkt sich das aus wer sitzt in
einem büro in köln bei rtl und denkt
sich bist du warst im nächsten video ein
bisschen junges mädchen und ihr freund
ist einfach ihr vater bevor wir etwas
schlauer sein anschlüssen heute zwei
kurze dinge nummer eins ich werde da wir
jetzt in jedem video meinen lieblings
kommentar von dem letzten video am
anfang vorlesen deswegen werde ja oft
auch beugen sei attraktiv in den
kommentaren denke ich etwas lustiges aus
oder schreibt der verein
das ist manchmal auch am lustigsten und
da werde ich im nächsten video
vielleicht auch erwähnt meinen lieblings
kommentare unter dem letzten video tic
tac toe dollar war von stephanie es das
beste an diesen videos ist seine sache
dankeschön dafür ich denke ich manchmal
echt bin ich meine videos zu schauen ist
mein lachen vielleicht zu krass weil du
dann so richtig behindert ausrastet
ich habe bezahlt nichts klar danke dafür
und jetzt immer zwei leute die
heutige folge wird ganz gut ohne max
ohne entweder einfach nur wir unten
richtig beschissen das video okay also
ich habe schon mal das pärchen um das es
geht er ist ziemlich breit und ziemlich
rot der südosten bisschen zu lange der
sonne liegen lassen sie also diese dinge
ist glaube ich etwas jünger also die so
aus wie 18 und die tief könnte so ende
30 sein also ungefähr 20 jahre
unterschied
wahrscheinlich ist er vater sind wir
letztlich wir schauen hilft mir
ich glaube ich spiele da habe ich es
wieder leute ein sehr großes problem in
unserem land peter können heutzutage
einfach nicht mehr ungestört beziehung
mit ihren töchtern führen was falsch
verstanden dass nicht eine tochter das
ist seine tochter
ich kann nicht sagen warum das mädchen
tochter nennt nicht wirklich deine
tochter ist aber sie ist der tochter und
jetzt dass vater und tochter mal
gemeinsam eine gute zeit haben okay da
übrigens ganz kurz das ist 17 und 40 23
jahre älter als sie muss los oder und
die person die sich gerade beschwert hat
ist die jahr 42 und jörg es auch noch
sehr guter freund andreas diesem beste
freunde also wir haben ein typen der
behauptet die vater zu sein aber
wahrscheinlich ist sie und den typen mit
dem sie zusammen ist mir wirklich ein
vater sein soll und auch der beste
freund von ihrem nicht möglich ein vater
ist vorüber sind
es geht zwar auf die du auf dein zimmer
sind seit über 20 jahren freuen uns bei
er wiederholt dabei von dem was sie
sagen der kriegt man sich so auch habe
ich mein ganzes leben damit falsch
aufgeregt ich dachte man sich aufregt
dann sagt man was einem selbst den kopf
geht und platz einfach aus einem raus
aber er wiederholt einfach nur was die
gesagt haben gesagt ich zeig dich an
wegen verfluchen
[Musik]
aber so okay wenn jetzt erwachsen
verflucht hat das ok aber minderjährigen
verfluchen nicht wieder bot wirklich die
ganze zeit was die sagt aber wir sind zu
sagen ihr seid zusammen
papa wir lieben uns auch hier liegt
durch paparazzi das thema reden drüber
reden obamas andreas ist mein bester
freund du weißt schon dass er über 20
jahre älter ist als du und das alter ist
für mich kein problem
das alter ist für diese junge dame kein
problem 17-jährige ist natürlich
selbstverständlicher weise mit einem 40
jährigen zusammen 40 jahre leute dieser
typ dieser andreas könnte kinder haben
die älter sind als sie ohne probleme
oder erwartet vielleicht auch kinder die
genau so alt sind wie sieht oder
vielleicht auch eine tochter die sie ist
und da hat die kleinen natürlich wieder
recht jeder vater sieht das liebend
gerne wenn der eigene frau hängt 40 ist
mit der eigenen tochter schläft was
könnte da schief gehen so oder sehen das
problem die junge dame hat ein viertes
gray post im hintergrund das wird
wahrscheinlich der busspur an gelöst
sein
liebe erzählen von liebe die sache dabei
ist heute ich glaube kein normaler
mensch würde auf die idee kommen dass
eine beziehung zwischen den 17 jährigen
und nur 40 jährigen irgendwie
ansatzweise normal ist aber stelle ich
mir das vor als die zehn war war er 33
und jetzt vielleicht ihr vater davon am
rande ist noch keine 18 maus das gibt's
doch nicht ganz so wie die drauf ist ich
würde nehmen in den keller sacken
einsparen
ok wenn die aktie ist kannst du machen
was du willst verein ab in den keller an
ketten sich jetzt hätte dass sie nicht
weiter mit 40 jährigen männern schläft
das gibt es nicht das kann doch nicht
wird das noch nicht wirklich durch die
sie sich ab ich begriff dass falsch
erweisen weil hilft wenn die darsteller
einfach selber merken was für eine
bilder details oder gerade abläuft und
einfach selbst lachen müssen in das bild
klar kann saskia jetzt überhaupt nicht
verstehen was ihr vater für ein problem
hat die ist verliebt das einzige was ich
machen könnte wäre mit seinem freund
andreas zu sprechen sagt sie was wir
machen könnte ist seine tochter im
keller an ketten glaub mir york sind die
gerade was das für eine wand der mitte
und ist jetzt im anderen haus machte mir
nicht so viel hingabe
das stimmt es kann doch echt nicht dein
ernst sein wie sich diese schauspielerin
und das glück hat jemand bei hilft mir
gesucht niemanden die schauspieler
lassen sich in so einer szene wo so
übelster streit sein sollte apple seien
abgedreht mehr passt
du packst jetzt seine sachen und
erfahren wir zusammen nach hause was
nein ganz sicher nicht
denn die gegend selbst kaum gebracht
einfach kein lachanfall zu bekommen
[Musik]
nein das ist das perfekte alter okay
wenn ich jetzt eine junge frau okay ich
werde es 23 angenommen ich wende 23
jahre alt die junge frau natürlich suche
ich mir dann nur männer aus die auch
mein vater sein können darum geht es
auch bei der ganzen sache also ich jetzt
ne frau treppe und merkel die es nicht
so weit dass ich meine mutter sein
könnte
was soll das heißen andreas für gar
nichts zeit da geht es gehe darum dass
du du bist jung vor 15 jahren als er 25
und schon ein erwachsener mann war hast
du noch windeln getragen
kleine rohde bekanntlich kennt die liebe
keine grenzen das gesetz schon hier ist
es so dass saskia 17 jahre alt ist sie
kann sich frei ihre sexualpartner
auswählen ich das denn der neue anwalt
hat ein haifischzahn um den hals muss
man das einmal um den hals tragen als
ich will ich hin wollte aber der letzte
anwalt sagt ihm er nach anwalt aus
arminia ist bestimmt immer noch wir wo
du haben stehen ja wo sie abends schläft
nicht mit wem sie schläft sie dachte ich
schon wieder ab ich muss es einfach
jedes mal sagen ich lasse es sollte aber
achtet drauf
die frau und die kann sich selbst nicht
ernst nehmen muss weil ich bin glücklich
oder kommt da kommt ja da kommt da rein
und ich muss sagen eine sache die mich
gewundert hat dieser andreasen sieht aus
als würde ohne weiteres besatz diaz
vater zusammen prügel seiner mutter
zusammen prügeln und dann noch den
kompletten stadtteil zusammen prügeln
aber bisher hält sich noch in grenzen
das ganze ist halt so weit dass kaspar
diesen typen sieht geht also von
normalen oder wird ganz ehrlich jetzt
jörg zars kates vater was ist los mit
dir ja okay dann bessere freunde eine
beziehung mit der tochter aber stelle
ich das nicht sagen
saskia hat entschieden für immer bei
andreas zu bleiben das betrifft
natürlich richtig entscheidung sie hat
heute in der schule das große einmaleins
gelernt und damit ist sie jetzt alt
genug um zu entscheiden mit wem sie bis
an ihr lebensende zusammen beide ganz
zum missfallen von ihren eltern und von
andreas so loritz
doch älter als hallo das ist der sohn
von dem typen mit denen sind die
beziehungen des cej älter als die und
warum kommt er zu ihren staat wenn er
weiß dass sie im bad ist und er hat
geduscht hat war mal nein bitte nicht
das war heute teil 2 von dieser folge
kommt direkt morgen damit er nicht lange
warten müsst hier gibt's noch um die
wartezeit bis morgen zu verkürzen
einfach ich vorgeschlagen des
videotextes gerne ab schaut weiter und
bis morgen